- We're about to play,
"Let's Make A Deal,"
to hopefully win some
money for these puppies
from Wagmore Pets, a dog rescue,
and you have a very special
connection with Wagmor.
- I do.
My latest Lord Chesterfield
was rescued from Wagmor.
- Well, everyone knows
that I love a game show
and who doesn't?
And what better way to
kick off Los Angeles Week
than a classic game show
"Let's Make A Deal."
(audience applauding)
So, everybody, welcome Wayne Brady.
(lively music)
- Hi, Wayne Brady, pleasure.
- Gorgeous.
- I know.
- Can you handle it?
- Is that your dog, Jen?
- No, he could be yours though.
- Oh, no I already got four.
I already have four.
Hey, y'all.
- All right, Wayne.
Thank you for honoring
us with your presence.
- Oh, it's my pleasure.
- I just visited you
in your premiere week.
- Yes, Ma'am.
- So thank you for coming today.
Tell us what we are playing for.
- All right, so, if you
know "Let's Make A Deal,"
you know that we love to
make a deal, of course.
So we're gonna play a game
called "How Much Is Enough?"
(audience applauding)
Now, easy-peasy game.
This first prize that you're playing for,
it is a picture of us on the
set of "Let's Make A Deal."
Now, do you keep this
picture, as amazing as it is,
and just walk away, it's yours,
or do you take a silver envelope?
And that silver envelope
will be brought into me by
The Money Fairy, aka Chris
Ahearn, one of our producers.
Thank you, Money Fairy.
(audience applauding)
- With all due respect to both of us,
I think I'm gonna go with the-
- Silver.
- Yeah.
- Right?
- Silver envelope, now, you
know, this could be a Zonk.
- A Zonk.
- But it isn't.
It's $25,000.
(audience applauding)
- [Jennifer] Oh, my God!
- So, you've got $25,000 for Wagmor.
Now, you can keep your $25,000
and your picture and just walk away.
Or you could take this gold envelope.
If-
(audience applauding)
If you decide to take the gold envelope
and there's a Zonk inside,
then you lose everything.
(audience yelling answers)
- What do you say, I'd say-
- I'm gonna say-
- [Wayne] That sounds like peer pressure.
- We're gonna go for yes, Wayne.
Please, gosh.
- Okay.
Remember when I said
that if this was a Zonk,
you lose everything?
- Yes, we remember!
- Okay.
(audience laughing)
I just got to reiterate.
- I know!
- Another $25,000!
- Oh, my God!
- Another $25,000 to Wagmor.
(audience applauding)
You now have $50,000.
- Yes.
(audience cheering)
- Plus the picture.
Which I'm so happy that you
get that because I'm a dog dad,
I've got four dogs.
So, yay Wagmor!
- Yay!
- Money Fairy, the big envelope, please.
(audience applauding)
Thank you!
If this is a Zonk, you lose everything.
So you can walk away right
now with your 50 grand.
- Remember, we talked about
not wanting to be greedy
and not being ambitious.
- Yes, I think we stick where we are.
- I do too.
- Stick it.
- So you're passing on the envelope?
- Oh, God!
- Oh, God, come on!
- Yes, yes, yes, yes, yes!
- Oh, my goodness.
You guys have shot films
all over the world.
Have you ever shot in Hungary?
- No.
(puppy whining)
No, he hates the idea.
- And I'm Hungarian.
- Okay, because what you
passed on, this is a Zonk
and, little known that Zonk is actually
the Hungarian translation of
"He's just not that into you."
- Oh!
- So, congratulations!
You missed out on a Zonk.
Let's hear it for Wagmor!
(audience applauding)
Miss Aniston, Drew, thank you.
So nice to meet you.
- Thank you so much, pleasure.
- Thank you, Wayne.
Thank you so-
- That is so cute!
- Thank you so much.
That's $50,000 and-
- $50,000, that's amazing.
- Would you like to hold?
- Sure!
- Because, I mean you
just, by the way, come on.
- Don't pee on me, baby.
- I think it's good.
All right, that's $50,000
and it'll go towards
Wagmor Pets Dog Rescue,
(audience applauding)
which Jennifer Aniston has brought
to the forefront of our attention.
It's an extraordinary
organization right here,
but you can support it from
all across the country.
We wanna send a huge
thank you to The Wildest,
your go-to pet-parents site
and pet DNA-decoder, Wisdom Panel,
for your donations in supporting
Wagmor Pets Dog Rescue.
Those are the two companies
that gave us the $25,000 today.
- Yay!
(audience applauding)
- And thank you so much
for supporting Wagmor!
Go to TheDrewBarrymoreShow.com
to find out more information
on The Wildest, Wisdom Panel,
and Wagmor Pets Dog Rescue.
And Wayne, thank you so much
for doing this with us and Jen.
- Thanks for having me.
- Pleasure to see you, Wayne.
- Be sure to check out "Let's
Make A Deal" today on CBS.
The morning show premieres
September 17th on Apple TV.
(bright music)